سام شكري مرحبا بك في البرنامج هل يمكنني أن
أبدأ بسؤالك ما هي المشكلة
في معبر رفح لماذا لا
تدخل المساعدات إلى غزة للناس بشكل جيد
حاليا أه هناك قافلة طويلة
من المساعدات الإنسانية
بين العريش ورفح مع شاحنات على
الجانب  الطريق في انتظار
إمكانية أه دخول غزة
معبر رع خلال الأيام الماضية تعرض
للقصف أربع مرات أه بينهم مرة
عندما كنا نحاول إصلاح بعض
الأضرار وأصيب أربعة عمال مصريين
أه المعبر تعرض
لأضرار في الطرق أه  طرق الوصول بين الجانب
المصري والجانب الغزاوي أه بها
أضرار جسيمة وتحتاج إلى إصلاح أه
وبالتالي ليس لدينا كذلك أي
تصريح في طرق واضحة أه آمنة
أه طرق آمنة لتتمكن تلك القوافل من
الدخول أه بأمان وبدون أي
إمكانية  استهدافهم أه
هذا هو الوضع والوضع الحالي
ونحن نعمل جاهدين على أمل
أن يكون هناك أه فتح وقدرة
على إصلاح المعبر حتى
تتمكن القوافل من الدخول هناك
حاجة كبيرة من الذين
تم استهدافهم  نازحين من شمال
غزة وهم الآن في ظروف انعدام
الغذاء والماء أه المأوى
ويعانون كثيرا أه لكن حتى الآن
لا يوجد ممر آمن تم
منحه ولا القدرة على إصلاح
الأضرار التي لحقت
بالمعبر  حسنًا، لقد رأينا شبكة سي إن إن
تُبلغ عن أنه كانت هناك بالفعل
غارات جوية حول رفح وقد
أظهرناها على الهواء اليوم أه أعمدة من
الدخان حول تلك المنطقة، سؤالي
لك على الرغم من ذلك هو حتى لو كانت مفتوحة وأنك
أحضرتها مسموحًا بها
القوافل الإنسانية في من أنتم على استعداد للسماح لهم
بالخروج لأنه من الواضح أن هناك
ضغط هائل يحاول الفلسطينيون الفرار
هل تقبلون عشرات مئات
الآلاف من الفلسطينيين اليائسين في
مصر
أرى أه أن هذا
سؤال متكرر يطرح علينا وأتساءل عما
إذا كان  لا ينبغي أن يكون أه
ما يجب أن يسمح به هو دخول
المساعدات الإنسانية ليتمكن
سكان غزة من البقاء على
أراضيهم أه أه ذلك النقل ذلك
التهجير أه مخالف
للقانون الدولي الإنساني لا
أفهم أه في  ما هو الغرض من
النقل إلا إذا كان مقصودًا
أعدادًا كبيرة من الأشخاص إلى بلد
يستضيف بالفعل 9 ملايين
لاجئ أه للحصول على تدفق إضافي
من هذا النوع أعتقد أن أه العديد من
الدول الأوروبية أه حساسة جدًا
لهذا  الموضوع وأه بذل كل ما
في وسعه لتجنبه أعلم أن
الولايات المتحدة لديها مشكلة على
حدودها الجنوبية وهي أنها تقيد دخول
طالبيها لذلك أتساءل لماذا مصر أه يفترض أنها ستسمح بتدفق
مليون أو اثنين  مليون
نسمة يعانون بسبب
العواقب المترتبة على استهدافهم
دون داع. أريد فقط أن أعرف
ما إذا كان من دواعي
القلق أيضًا أنه لن يُسمح لهم
بالعودة أبدًا، على سبيل المثال،
قال الأردنيون إن أي محاولة لنقل الفلسطينيين
من المناطق المحتلة  تعتبر الضفة الغربية
خطًا أحمر بالنسبة لهم، وأنا أتساءل عما إذا كنت
تشعر بالقلق مثل القادة العرب الآخرين،
وبالتأكيد الفلسطينيين، من أنه
حتى لو سمحت لهم بالدخول، فسيكون ذلك بمثابة
نهاية لقدرتهم على العودة إلى
غزة جيدًا، وهذا بالتأكيد
احتمال وأه قد يكون
نية أه يتم
تهجيرهم قسراً وأن يفقدوا
ممتلكاتهم ويفقدوا أه
وطنهم أه
لأغراض سياسية وهذا
انتهاك قطعاً إذا لم يشكل حرباً
جريمة في حد ذاتها التهجير التهجير
القسري لمجموعة
بهذا الحجم من السكان هو أمر غير مبرر
وغير مبرر. هل يمكنني أن أسألك عن الرهائن
هل أنت متورط على الإطلاق في محاولة إقناع
حماس بالإفراج عن الرهائن. هل
تعرف من هو الجميع وأعتقد من هو؟
المعنيون في المنطقة أه حريصون على
معالجة هذه القضية وأه ضمان
سلامة وإطلاق سراح جميع
الرهائن المدنيين والتاريخ أه
ديس فلسطيني كذلك أعتقد أه
أنه سيخفف التوترات الحالية
وهو ضروري بسبب أه
طبيعة أه أي شكل من أشكال الهجوم على
المدنيين أه مهما كان السياق لدينا
سنطبق بالتأكيد
أه للتعامل مع مختلف جوانب
الصراع والأزمة بما في ذلك
الرهينة إذا أتيحت لنا
الفرصة لذلك أخيرا هناك
تقرير مهم  تقول أن
رئيس استخباراتك اتصل بإسرائيل،
وخاصة بنيامين نتنياهو،
لتنبيهه بشأن شيء شرس يحدث
من غزة قبل أيام قليلة من الهجوم. وقد
نفى نتنياهو ذلك، لكن
لجنة الشؤون الخارجية في الكونجرس الأمريكي
قالت إنها استمعت أيضًا إلى هذه التقارير،
فماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا؟  بخصوص ذلك لا
ليس لدي معلومات في هذا الصدد ما
يمكنني قوله لك هو أنه منذ أكثر من
عام ونصف أو أكثر لدينا
باستمرار في جميع مناقشاتنا أه
مع حلفائنا وأصدقائنا في
الولايات المتحدة مع أصدقائنا في إسرائيل
وفي المنطقة كنا
نحذر دائما من أن دوامة العنف
ستعود إذا بقي الركود السياسي الحالي
وعدم التوصل
إلى حل أه للصراع وإقامة
الدولة الفلسطينية على هذه الحالة أه أه
غير  -التنفيذ أن هذه دورات
شهدناها في الماضي،
وهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
تندلع فيها غزة، وهذه هي المرة الرابعة التي يكون لدينا فيها
أبوان مشتركان في الضفة الغربية
وفي الأراضي المحتلة،
ويأتي هذا في أعقاب
الإحباط وعدم الإنجاز
وعدم تنفيذ
حل الدولتين أه وأعتقد
تحذيراتنا تحذيرات عامة
وتوقع هذا في هذا الصدد مرة أخرى
تم أه وضعه كتقييم دقيق أه
فقط على المستوى الشخصي
ثم هل صدمت بما حدث بما
حدث في 7 أكتوبر
أوه بالتأكيد بكل تأكيد
مروع لرؤية أي صورة
أه تستهدف المدنيين إنه أه
غير مقبول على الإطلاق أه المدنيون أه لا ينبغي
بأي حال من الأحوال أن يخضعوا لأي شكل من أشكال
النشاط العسكري وأه  لقد كانت
صدمة شيء مؤسف سما
شكري وزيرة الخارجية من مصر شكرا
جزيلا لانضمامك إلينا شكرا لك